Then the question was about chlorinated pools.
This chlorine bad for us, I want to go to a hotel and I want to go
to the pool and I'm going to be in with chlorine.
Well, chlorine is a toxin.
So chlorine is obviously used to kill bacteria.
It's an antibacterial antifungal.
It works quite well, but it is poisonous to us.
And it can cause a lot of problems.
I've had several patients that their main problem was a chlorine toxicity.
But I will say every one of those patients were swimmers.
So they were in a chlorine pool several hours a day.
So the best way to reduce chlorine is get it out of your drinking water.
I don't believe that you absorb a ton of chlorine through your skin.
Your skin is a barrier.
You shouldn't be absorbing a lot of chlorine through your skin.
So if you're going to swim in a chlorine pool and you're going to do it every day,
well, then that could lead to problems for you.
You could get on a key later on a regular basis so that it won't lead to problems.
However, you have to be careful if you have metal in your mouth.
There's a whole bunch of other steps that you want to follow.
So you're going to have to contact me directly if that's your issue.
So if you're, if I can't remember who was asked this question,
but if the question is, I go to the health club and I want to go swim in every day,
I just love to go swim in every day.
Well, there's a lot of chlorine in a pool like that.
If you're not drinking the water, you could be just fine.
Plus, if you're doing other things, you're not drinking chlorinated water at home.
And you're taking a key later, you could be just fine.
So some people are going to be more susceptible to heavy metal toxicity than others.
And I consider this a heavy metal toxicity.
So it's a, if you're just going to, I'm going on a trip,
but I'm going to go swim into the pool, don't worry about it.
Go on the trip and swim in the pool.
But if you want to do it on a daily basis,
then maybe we need to have a chat.
It's very important that you're not ingested it because most people have damaged gut borders.
Most people are not walking around with damaged skin borders.
That's called a wound.
And yes, if you have an open wound, you shouldn't be swimming in a chlorine pool.
But most people have damaged gut borders.
You have wounds in your intestinal tract.
And if you swallow chlorine, you're going to absorb it
because it's going to get across the damaged border that's called leaky gut.
So make sure you're using the filtration system if you live in the city
so that you're not getting fluoride, and chlorine, fluoride is probably even worse.
Chloride also kills your bacteria in your intestines
because it's an anti-macterial.
So drinking chlorinated water all the time is like taking an antibiotic all the time.
You're just, that's part of the reason why we have such damaged guts.
So GMO foods and chlorine is a big contributor to damaged guts.
That's part of the reason why we have such damaged guts.